let's go next - why don't we go to our
caller from the six - six area code
who's calling today from six to six hi
that me that is you hi this is AJ from
California I wanted to talk to you
specifically about press freedom so
kettering as you've covered within the
past that the u.s. is ranked 48th
currently in press freedom and
considering based on how you discovered
that Trump allies are specifically
targeting strategically opposition to
the presidency what is it that we can do
as progressives to target this narrative
strategically moving forward not
necessarily just within this
administration but also I would say
within the future because the
president's been established that it is
an unstable State for the media to be
and not just with an independent media
outlets as you've experienced but even
mainstream media outlets are
theoretically supposed to keep this
presidency accountable yep so there's a
lot of different things that can be done
and it really sort of depends like how
much activism can we coalesce around
this issue at the very micro level we
want to be sure that when we are
electing whether it's representatives or
senators or whoever make this issue of
press freedom an issue force them to
take positions on it and let's try to
elect people that are not going to allow
press freedom to be eroded but of course
that's easier said than done there's big
money - interests that impact who the
candidates even are that we're choosing
between so I understand that number two
we want to make sure that we are
properly supporting the media outlets
that you want to see doing stuff and
this is not me saying go get a David
Pakman show membership but for for
newspapers and magazines that are doing
good investigative journalism that you
like part of their ability to do it is
access and that is controlled sometimes
by the White House or whoever but part
of it is also having the resources to
actually do these investigations so we
want to make sure that we're also
putting our money where our mouths are
and saying not only that we support
press freedom but actually supporting it
financially as well and then it would be
great to you know we have a First
Amendment in this country but I would
love to see some further specific
codification of limits as to what can be
done to
antagonize media by the federal
government put in place and maybe some
of it has to be precedent set via the
judiciary but none of this stuff is
going to happen while you have half the
country basically hypnotized and
bamboozled by this fake news meme that
Donald Trump is so successfully used and
that's got to be fixed first and then
follow-up question to that to what
extent does that strategy tangibly
translate the combating stochastic
terrorism especially since I would say
that right-wing media consistently
ameliorate to that on pretty much every
level will be it with the
anti-immigration rhetoric anti-india
rhetoric etc and you've covered that
consistently as someone who has been
inspired by you to start its own media
outlet I'm very aware of trying to
understand what I can do to try and
combat stochastic terrorism outside of
just promoting it considering that I
haven't necessarily seen legal
repercussions and yet we still see the
death and we still see the fallout from
it well the best way not to promote
stochastic terrorism is by not not
putting out ideas that given a big
enough audience would translate to
real-world violence and so but merely by
not doing that you're already
participating and at least trying to
solve the problem okay great yeah thank
you so much and one suggestion real
quick in terms of a future segment how
do you feel about answering what the
future of our foreign policy agenda
should be as progressives because then
Dixon pointed out that we need to ask
that question try and solve it and I
trust your judgment on solving that
question alright very good I will put it
on my list and hope to get to it let's
take a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up we're going right back to
the phones right after this